hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
in cold Fusion's early days back in the
early to mid-2010s a lot of Android
phones would make their way onto the
channel one very common feature among
these phones was use a replaceable
batteries at the time carrying a spare
battery in your pocket wasn't that
unusual of an occurrent but have you
ever wondered what happened to that
nowadays thanks to industry-wide design
changes glass glue and metals have
become the industry standard for
materials because of this easily
replaceable batteries are no longer
possible this just been the way things
have been for the better part of a
decade but things are about to change in
a sweeping new law by the European
Parliament replaceable battery products
will be forced back into fashion the law
will have an effect on phones tablets
and laptops not just in Europe but
worldwide in this episode we'll take a
quick look
we were watching cool Fusion TV
[Music]
in June of 2023 the European Parliament
voted 587 to 9 in a bid to force all
consumer devices to have easily
replaceable batteries easily replaceable
means that the battery changing process
should require no special tools this
means manufacturers can no longer use
adhesives the direct quote from the EU
is that battery replacement should
require quote no tool or set of tools
that is supplied with the product or
spare part or basic tools the process
for replacement shall be able to be
carried out by a Layman
almost all smartphones today are
designed like a glass sandwich this was
the design that was settled upon as the
smartphone market matured the glass
sandwich method of construction is Sleek
and thin but relies on an extensive use
of adhesives this law would mean that
the very fundamentals of how companies
design phones will need to change unless
companies figure out a new way to build
the same phones without adhesives
manufacturers from Apple to Google to
Samsung will be affected
foldable phones will face a huge
challenge when trying to comply with
these laws so we'll have to wait and see
on that front
so how does the law in the EU possibly
affect the rest of the world well it's
likely that phone manufacturers aren't
going to design a specific phone for the
EU
reason being it's expensive so it's
going to eat into their profit
Apple for example is unlikely to design
a European iPhone with a replaceable
battery and another iPhone with a sealed
battery for other regions this EU lore
will have a Rippling consequence across
the world
but it goes further the law also affects
tablets laptops EVS e-bikes and
basically anything with a rechargeable
battery in July of 2023 the law was
approved by the European Council and
will come into effect in 2027. this
gives over three years for manufacturers
to get their act together this will be
an especially big change for Apple who
have never featured removable batteries
since the very first iPhone Samsung
stopped featuring removable batteries on
their flagships back in 2014. so many
people think that waterproofing and dust
proofing will be much harder to achieve
but right to repair Advocate Lewis
Rossman argues some good points so I am
old enough to remember when this was not
a repair but maintenance and I'm also
old enough to remember that Society
seems to have this Collective Amnesia
regarding water resistance there was an
article going over this where it said
that one needs to be aware that
incorporating easily removable bags will
mean these handsets will lose water
resistance unless a well thought out
design is undertaken again selective
amnesia for the phases like the Samsung
S5 which is IP67 or the Sony xb10 which
is ip68 this device is ip68 with a user
removable battery
some others argue that removable
batteries will make smartphones bulky
and less premium but the LG G5 proved
that it was possible to make a phone
thin premium and with a removable
battery right to repair campaigns
coordinator Christina gnapi calls the
ruling quote a big success for right to
repair
[Music]
for those of you unfamiliar right to
repair is a movement that calls for
consumer goods to be easily repairable
we've all seen the trend when your TV or
phone is broken it's more common for
people to just buy a new one instead of
repairing it this is due to the
components becoming more complex and
integrated over time but some companies
are straight up anti-consumer in this
context apple is the biggest culprit if
you own a later model iPhone and the
screen breaks and you go to replace it
with a perfectly good screen from the
same model Apple will disable some
features and warn you that it's not
genuine
the same goes for replacing the battery
or camera and even if they are genuine
parts but don't have the same serial
number things don't work as they should
this wasn't the case for older Apple
products it's an effort to make their
users send their devices only to Apple
so an exorbitant fee can be extracted
from consumers further to this apple
does not supply diagnostic software and
they've even raided repair shops for
having a large stock of genuine repair
parts
let's say that in your MacBook you have
a broken display Flex cable Apple
intentionally connects the display Flex
Cable in such a way that you can't just
replace the cable you have to replace
the entire display and this can cost
over 700 or a wire to it if we're
looking at a flex cable a flex cable
that is less than 50 cents I'm telling
people I'm telling technicians that get
paid 30 to 50 an hour spend an hour
trying to fix this Flex cable that costs
50 cents because we're not allowed to
replace it so if the pads are missing we
have to start scraping away with a
dental pick and hope that we can solder
a little jumper wire onto a flex cable
to reattach it to a chip that was
corroded that we then have to file away
at to get to the metal because I can't
put a new 50 Cent Hall sensor on that
person's MacBook because if I do it
won't work I understand the argument for
Apple wanting safer repairs but should
this mean that even a qualified external
repair technician should be blocked from
helping people with their damaged
devices
of course Apple isn't the only company
that does this but for the context of
this story they're the most relevant
[Music]
so what's the intention of this law
the new law isn't for consumers as much
as it is to protect the environment
today when a phone's battery dwindles
after a few years it's much easier for
the common user to just buy a new one
instead of repairing it over 50 million
annual tons of E-Waste is generated this
way the European Parliament is making
sure that the environmental impacts of
batteries is considered they're aiming
to create a circular economy for
batteries
this means that in a product life cycle
as little as possible of the battery's
raw materials should be wasted
here are some rules covered by the law
pertaining to replaceable batteries
phone manufacturers will need to collect
63 of portable batteries that would
normally go into landfill by the end of
2027. lithium recovery from waste
batteries will need to be at 50 percent
by 2027 and EV batteries will need to be
made of certain percentages of
recyclable content initially 16 Cobalt
85 lead 6 lithium and six percent nickel
all batteries should have a recycling
efficiency Target of 50 by 2025.
this all sounds fine but the first point
seems difficult getting consumers to
responsibly give their older phone
batteries back to the manufacturer will
be tricky to enforce we'll have to see
[Music]
so it's unlikely that there's going to
be any changes in the next few months to
a year but after this Smartphone makers
will have to start gearing up for
compliance with a new law we'll start to
see the results of these efforts over
the next few years I did say earlier
that it's unlikely that manufacturers
will Design two different phones an
iPhone for Europe and another for the
rest of the world but anything is
possible really
it's also going to be fascinating to see
what happens to laptops e-bikes and EVS
regardless things are going to be shaken
up in the next few years and an
interesting question that I post to you
is do you think that the phasing out of
user replaceable batteries was just the
natural progression of design as
dictated by consumer demand or are these
changes motivated by profit resulting in
anti-consumer products let me know what
you think in the comments section below
if you want to see another cold fusion
episode on battery recycling I'll link
that below oh and the third and final
episode of my AI series with the
Australian Broadcasting Corporation will
be live soon
I'll leave a link for that in the
description below cheers guys have a
good one
[Music]
all right
cold fusion it's me thinking